[Music]
one of my favorite plants to complement
the gardener Peppers peppers come in
lots of different shapes and sizes they
certainly come in lots of flavors and
there should be a pepper that just about
anyone can use and like Peppers do well
in a high organic matter soil and they
love full sun they have to be planted
after the last frost but they do survive
pretty well in cooler weather and then
when they really start growing is when
it really gets warmed up they tolerate
heat better than almost all of our
garden vegetables they like warm
temperatures enough that they do really
well in in hoop houses green houses and
that type of situation where we're
adding heat there's hot peppers there's
mild Peppers you can eat them like an
apple and then there's some that boy you
don't want to eat plain peppers are
wonderful to use in your garden to
complement your other vegetables they
grow really well and they do well in
most Gardens they have all types of uses
in the kitchen you can take the hot
peppers the smaller peppers and just pop
them in a Ziploc bag put them in the
freezer you've got them all all winter
long to use the bigger sweet peppers we
can dice them up put them in an old
style ice cube tray with water freeze
them and then pop them in a Ziploc bag
anytime you're going to make fresh salsa
or soups just take them out and put them
in what you want to use of course the
best way to eat a pepper is to eat the
sweet ones like an apple All Summer Long
warm off the vine this is Hudson Hill
with the University of voling extension
you're watching from the ground
up
[Music]